let's talk about 5g the latest and
greatest mobile network that they say is
going to transform our lives
[Music]
it sounds promising 5g will let us
download an HD movie in seconds
that's just hilariously fast doctors
will be able to perform remote surgery
with virtually no lap time and it'll
make self-driving cars smarter and safer
but there are also suspicions that 5g
will expose us to more security breaches
privacy issues and even health problems
so what exactly is 5g and how much of
the excitement or fear is just
heightened we all know 3G and 4G they're
the mobile networks we use today you see
them at the top of your phone and they
give us access to the Internet but we're
now making way for the next generation
5g is promoted as the best and fastest
connection around and in some countries
it's already available South Korea
launched 5g networks last year
so did providers in China the UK the US
and Germany new 5g phones are on the way
to Samsung released the first one in
2019 bringing commercial 5g to life
before the rest so here is how it works
5g uses a wide range of radio
frequencies starting from the lower end
which we already use for television and
Wi-Fi all the way up to what's called
millimeter waves which are extremely
high frequency and used for things like
radar guns and security screening at
airports
this means that VG can carry huge
amounts of data faster and that's a big
reason why we need it our mobile
networks are running out of capacity
soon they won't be able to accommodate
the growing number of devices were using
and there's money to be made
governments will earn revenue by
granting 5g licenses the other reason to
move to 5g innovation we have more
sensors in the world
clocking data and transmitting them back
and forth in a smart intelligent hybrid
way
it is sort of like a Jetsons like
futuristic technology my ingredients and
I get recipes he's talking about what
they call the Internet of Things and
what it means is more and more of our
devices like smart speakers or exercise
equipment will remember and even
anticipate our preferences and five gene
will allow them to talk to each other at
a record speed it will be connecting
many more devices to the Internet for
the same probably amount of money and
without interfering one to each other
the challenge with 5g is coverage
shorter wavelengths carry more
information but are more easily blocked
by things like trees and walls with 4G
transmitters or base stations can be
several kilometers apart but with 5g
they need to be closer which means we
need more of them one estimate suggests
the US alone will have to install 1
million new towers that's why 5g is
really more of a gradual rollout not a
launch because all of that back-end
infrastructure will take years to build
what we're going to see as a substantive
replacement or upgrade of the course
systems that telecommunications
companies provide that's going to be a
really massive investment the problem in
some places is that big phone companies
have only just finished building their
4G networks they want to both enjoy the
benefits from the week the profits of
money they put into it but also they
recognize that well there's this
assertion that we're in a 5g race it's
not a short-term race it's a very
long-term marathon and the race is
already getting crowded some of the big
names in 5g are Ericsson from Sweden
Nokia and Finland and Samsung from South
Korea but one company is way in the lead
today as the world's biggest supplier of
networked telecommunications equipment
Huawei has been bidding for contracts
around the world to set up 5g networks
but the Chinese company isn't welcome in
a lot of places Australia New Zealand
Taiwan and Japan have all blocked Huawei
from building their 5g networks so as
the u.s. the Trump administration has
even put pressure on the UK Poland and
Germany to stop them from working with
Huawei there's an obvious business
reason for that Huawei has been crushing
the competition and the Americans want
in but the country's shutting cual way
out say there's more to it for the US
and many Western nations the tech giant
is a spying tool for the Chinese
government Chinese law requires these
firms to support and assist Beijing's
vast security apparatus allegations its
top executives deny they insisted
Huawei's not in the pocket of China's
government Huawei is basically accused
of being a pawn in China's
state-sponsored spying and there's an
assumption that you know in terms of
cyber crime and cyber war there's like a
bluff on the east that's leaving all
these attacks there's a strong
expectation at least in North America
and parts of Western Europe that
relations with China will become more
antagonist ik not you know due to a
military conflict is something of that
nature but on the basis of trade on
foreign policy on human rights and
issues like that but 5g also stirs up a
lot of debate about our own individual
privacy we're facing a future where more
and more of our basic household items
will be connected to a 5g network that's
a lot more data being collected like
what you watch on TV where your car is
and whether there's someone at home if
information advertisers are after and
it's data that others might want to
misuse and so if you are acquiring baby
monitors or you're acquiring door locks
or any of the other Internet of Things
things really looking at them carefully
to determine whether the vendor is
committed to providing a secure product
on an ongoing basis which brings us to
another concern our health with all
those extra radio waves swimming around
us people are worried
[Music]
when that dimension getting the infant's
Qiao's ball protests yet people are
gonna have a choice anymore and that's
what terrifies me the most we've seen
this before when mobile phones first
came out people were worried they might
cause cancer right now there is some
exposure your your deep tissues your
brain some other you know tissues that
are a few centimetres past the surface
of the skin but after many scientific
studies the general consensus is there's
no hard evidence to support that theory
but it hasn't necessarily been disproven
either
it's the same with 5g and in fact some
experts seem to think 5 G's shorter
wavelengths are actually less harmful
than the radiation from devices we're
using now it's just a little ironic to
me that people are already about 5g when
once you get to that millimeter wave
regime all your deep tissues are quite
safe it's really only your skin this
Punk you get any exposure it's the same
pattern with any new technology right
there's excitement and Wonder but also
skepticism but we're talking maybe 5 to
20 years before we really see 5g in full
effect and in that time new tech is
going to emerge China says it's already
working on the 16th
I hope that was a useful primer on 5g
and Wyatt's in the news as always
aljazeera.com has the story covered so
make sure to subscribe like and follow
all of our social media pages to get the
very latest I'll see you next week
[Music]